hello everyone thanks thanks for coming
and thanks to the organizer for putting
together this very interesting
conference I'm going to present a
project that I'm working on at the bank
of england with with some colleagues
obviously it's our own research work I
mean there's the usual disclaimers these
are not the views of the the Bank of
England and this is as a set of working
in progress project use some data that
are available to estimate something that
we currently don't have good indices of
land prices in the UK Emma straight say
straight from the beginning that we use
some Python in the in the project but
the presentation is more about the data
and what's available out there and the
conclusion we can draw from the data
rather than fight on techniques Python
code so so if if you want to leave no
worries okay so let me start by this
right this is these are house prices in
England and Wales for the last 20 years
and these are clearly important
variables to take into account mostly
because if we take the wealth of
households house is is the biggest asset
the biggest element for those hours old
especially in the United Kingdom if we
takes bank's balance sheet we have the
same thing houses are the most important
item however maybe one point that is is
known but perhaps not not discussed
enough is the fact that you can always
conceptualize a house as a bundle of two
different things one is a structure or a
building and the other element is the
land beneath it why this is interesting
because structure is reproducible you
can always buy a build the same
structure somewhere else land is not
Landis is unique and also from this
translates to some interesting macro con
Amick facts that make land land price is
more interesting than structured prices
so here I kept the house price index
that I showed before is dash line on an
annual basis and in red I plot the
building costs for the UK in the same
period as you can see building costs yes
are increasing but they have a much
smoother pattern over the years because
basically they depend on the salary of
builders and the cost of material so
it's more like an inflation type of of
series whereas the booms and busts that
we are used to to see in the housing
market they don't come they certainly
don't come from building costs this
means that if if a house is structure
plus and it must be the land is the more
volatile of two elements indeed if we
keep the same series as before house
prices but we now compare house prices
to land prices in the red on the red
line we see that how land prices were
very volatile in the run-up to the
housing boom and in the subsequent crush
so land prices we if the land prices
would give them a value of 100 in 1995
they went up to more than 500 at the
peak of of the boom now the interesting
thing in this graph is that the the
series for land prices stops in 2010 why
because the valuation of his agency was
in charge of producing this this series
stopped doing so and this for many
people has been a problem since then
here I have quoted an open letter to the
government of 2013 by you know a former
member of the Bank of England monetary
policy committee a professor from the
London School of Economics and there
were other other people who signed and
then they say you know the Terminator
terminating the publication of this data
makes it much harder for government to
understand the consequences of current
policy interventions in the house
market Ultra says the case for future
reform and more recently in March of
this year a former deputy governor of
the Bank of England Charlie bean
produced his review this important
review of UK economic statistics and
said that inadequate land market
statistics potentially hinder a suitable
supply response to the housing short and
it's easy to see why many parts of the
government old substantial amount of
land and the decision to release this
land for development obviously depend on
what you know about the price of this
land and our information is very limited
or the other hand also for developers
not to know what's the price of land the
exact price of land in different local
authorities this limits limits the
potential of investing in you in new
housing now what do we do in this
project so we we try to using available
data to plug this gap in UK statistics
so the available data that we use comes
from the England and Wales land registry
and this would be data is freely
available to everyone and the other part
comes from the Ordnance Survey maps the
Ordnance Survey is a part of the UK
government that produces maps that are
commercially sold some parts of the
government can have access to those maps
for free others have to buy them one
thing that we don't tackle we haven't
acted so far but it's interesting to
check in the future is whether the same
things that we do can be done with more
like open source Maps like open street
maps etc so we leave this for future
investigation and also an optional data
set that we will use in the future is
information on building costs from the
Royal Institution of Chartered Surveyors
so what we do with this information and
i will show you the details in the next
slide we estimate land and structure
values for properties for which we see
the price the transaction price in the
Land Registry and then with all this
data
we can create local and aggregate land
price indices so to read state again the
basic idea behind this work is that each
time you see a house that is transacted
you observe the price and this is
available for from the land registry
price paid data and you what we try to
do is to decompose this this price is
into a structure value and a land value
and we are mostly interested in the in
the land value okay so let's let's see
more in details what the data looks like
so the first most important perhaps data
set is the Land Registry price paid data
said this is available on the internet
on the government website and the data
set contains for the last 20 years all
the residential transactions in England
and Wales with price address complete
address and date now something that data
said that also comes from the land
registry perhaps less used are these
maps of land parcels so every time a
free old property is sold it comes
together with a piece of land the land
registry's leverage we obviously have
maps of these land plots and these maps
are actually published on the internet
local authority by local authority so
this is a very important element of our
analysis now to work on these maps we
need we need a software and we we use
QGIS of which we will talk more in a
couple of sites but this is what you get
when you when you open one of these
fines this is the London borough of
Camden and I will show you more zoomed
pictures later but is all the land plots
all the free old land plots on Don in
Camden right so this type of information
this type of geographic information is
structured according to this this idea
this geographic information system where
all the data is is putting layers and
you could have a layer that it that is
about addresses a layer that is about
elevation and shapes ground shapes etc
etc and the way I mean the software to
to analyze this type of data is one we
use is quantum GIS is an open-source
software to view edit and in general
work with geographic data it's a very
good software and one very useful
feature of quantum GIS is that there is
you can run easily run Python code with
it there is a Python console and
contributors can create plugins that are
very useful to automate some some tasks
that often arise when you analyze this
kind of data now I've talked about land
registry data said that we use upset the
other element are these maps by owner
survey so master map is the main product
master map is masmut goal is to map all
the objects found on well the main
object panel on the Great Britain
territory in this includes buildings of
course water like rivers lakes roads etc
now it's a very big data set we can
selectively on choose only certain
elements of this data set and for us
what matters are buildings so this is a
snapshot of buildings that are in the
Camden area now what's interesting that
all the elements in this in these
Geographic files come
with attributes and one attribute that
is that ordnance survey recently started
to to add to a dataset is building
heights this is super important because
if we're interested in the structure
value of buildings obviously the the
height of the building is something we
need we need to take into account
seriously right so we have now from our
two sources we have Land Registry plots
and buildings what we want to do because
we we have no direct way of putting this
tooth together we need an algorithm that
for each land plot matches a building or
for each building matches the land plot
and we need to obviously impose some
condition and the most obvious one is
that for a match to occur you must have
that the building is totally completely
inside the land plot now luckily there
are plugins python plugins that do this
in quantum GIS and therefore we use one
of those one of those now obviously they
could be cases where more buildings are
inside the same land plot or more land
plot are attached to the same building
but actually these ones this case occur
very very rarely so for the moment we
discard them so that's the set of Python
plugins that has proven to be super
super useful for what we do you know
this this Python functions and programs
can do all sorts of things what we are
particularly interested in is merging
layers so we can put local authorities
together and if we have enough power
memory could potentially draw a map of
the entire England and Wales all the
land plots and buildings in the entire
territory of England ways and the
spatial John is is to put together to
overlap buildings and land plots
and that's the other that's where you
can find those plugins now this is the
result of matching land and buildings
again i will show you even more zoomed
pictures later so in green you have
buildings in yellow land plots but you
do see that the boundaries between one
property and the other which is which is
crucial sometimes those boundaries are
not cannot be seen in the real word so
that's why Land Registry maps are really
really important one last thing before
we put back this data into the Land
Registry price paid data where we have a
match between buildings and land but we
don't have the addresses of those
buildings because and that's what we
need to link the building size and the
land sizes to the transaction data we
need addresses now luckily Ordnance
Survey as this address based data set
which is a complete set of all addresses
in Britain and luckily address base as
the building as a building ID in it
which can be linked to the master map
buildings so the matches is quite easy
now we can we have addresses for each of
the buildings and we can see whether
those buildings those houses were sold
in the last 20 years see the price and
decompose the price into a structure and
the land component so in the last part
of the second half of my toga so I'll
show you some some preliminary results
from from this exercise one thing that i
mentioned need to mention before is now
that to actually met or to get at the
land values depending on whether you had
data on construction costs and possibly
depreciation of structures now if you
have this data you first estimate the
building value so you you know the size
of the building now there are
there are data sets that give you the
construction cost per square meter per
or per floor area of these buildings and
there are data sets also give you
information on the depreciation because
of course you need to take into account
depreciation not all buildings are brand
new now if you add this data you first
estimate the value the structure value
for all your buildings and then when you
have a transaction price you get at the
land value by subtracting from the
transaction price the value of the
building so that's that will be the most
precise method but you need a data on
construction costs you don't have data
on construction costs you could still do
something that is that gives you a
meaningful answer and it's the
regression method so the price we have
it this comes from transaction data from
the land registry price paid data
building size we have either in square
meters if you use the plane map or cubic
meters if you also use the information
on building height and we have land size
from our land registry maps so by
running a simple linear regression you
can gather these two coefficient into 1
and beta 2 which represent the implied
structure value for square meters and
the implied land value for square meters
so so this will give you another way to
gather those those values which are
which are of interest for us now the
building cost information what we have
found is that there is these the Royal
Institution of Chartered Surveyors
publishes this datum they come at a cost
but they can be both and what's
interesting is that they have building
cost information by local authority an
ear and since we have data on the entire
England as and ways for 20 years this
breakdown is is super useful and also
they have valuation of depreciated
replacement costs and that's really what
we
we are after because we don't really
want to know what's the value of a
building if we build it again knew we
would like to see the current value of a
building now why is this data out there
because insurance companies have this
information because they insure
structures against fire and other other
incidents well we haven't purchased this
data yet so now I'm going to show you
some results with the regression method
and to build an example III I chose this
to postcode district one is in London
and then be five in the Camden borrow
and the other is in Swindon sn25 now
these are these two post codes are very
different that's why they can make for a
good example on purpose i've kept for
the two postcode the same range of
values on the vertical axis to highlight
the differences now in swindon is sn25
we have had in the past 20 years come in
relative terms many how sales but the
average price in relative term as
compared to the price in central areas
of london has been quite low and the
opposite side of the spectrum in a
postcode like nw5 we've had very few
sales I have to say that a focus here on
only on houses not not flat sales and a
prices that have been going up
dramatically this is a picture of our
geographic data on sn25 but perhaps it's
more interesting to see the zoomed
version so that's really get this really
gets at the heart of what we're doing so
the green rectangles or the green shapes
here are the buildings for which we know
the sizes and the rectangles around the
buildings are the land plot
that are associated with those with
those buildings now you see that you
usually the shapes are quite similar and
the land plot shades are also similar
however there is variation in the data
you see some properties that have a big
or long garden and a relatively small
building and vice versa you see other
properties with a bigger building a
smaller garden so this variation in the
data allows the statistical regression
to estimate a value for that extra
square meter of land or the extra square
meter or cubic meter of structure and
this is what we we exploit yeah this is
some some scatter plots from the data to
get a sense of the kind of information
we we are working with now the first the
first scatter plot on the left is the
relation between building area and land
area now of course one thing that jumps
jumps out and which is expected is that
land area is always larger than bending
area this is almost a requirement a
sanity check of the data indeed in the
few cases where this doesn't happen and
we consider those case outliers and we
would drop them but this scatter plot
also highlights one potential problem of
the regression method to which to which
we we need to find solutions if the
problem gets it gets to to see use so
there is a very high correlation between
building size and land size so there is
a big correlation between two variables
in linear regression it could be that
some of the some of the building
structure picks up the effect of land
and vice versa so we need to take this
into into account the other to scatter
plots plot building area against price
and land air
against price and that's a again a
scientist check I mean we would expect
price to rise with these two variables
and this is what we what we see although
perhaps we both both those variables we
see that price rise with a steep slope
at first but perhaps especially wheel
and then flattens a bit towards when we
get to to to big land land plots
curiosity may be in the scatter plot is
that you see some discontinuity at
250,000 in in swindon that is because
the old stamp duty system there was a
threshold at 250 so it didn't make a lot
of sense to price the house at 251
rather people would stop at 250 right so
this is the the first really you know
plane regression that that we run it's
just as I set price on land size and
structure size by year and what's
interesting we know that the results
won't be as precise as we would like
them to be without those building cost
information that we are collecting so
perhaps what's interested to do here is
to compare the two postcodes and to see
if the results at least match our our
expectations and I would say they do
because if we first start from structure
we see that structure is more expensive
in NW 5 and it will look a land land
again is more expensive in NW 5 however
we get the impression that the the
difference in structure is is smaller
than the difference in the two land
price which is what we would expect the
problem here is it seems that nw5
structure prices are picking up
especially at the end of the sample a
lot of variation that is probably due to
land prices
structure I mean we don't see in the
general building cost index such an
increase in the in the last part of the
sample so what we can do is to is to say
okay building costs they will differ
from one area to the other but it's
difficult to imagine that that those
differences we have dramatically
different trends so we could impose to
evolve to tackle this multicollinearity
problem between building an area we
could impose structure cost is the same
is in sn25 and in nw5 in this way the
shape of the line will be similar and
there will only be a jump level jump
between sn25 and nw5 now if we make this
assumption then the land prices in NW 5
we will pick up all the variation and
this is what we would expect from the
theory that we have in mind again
obviously there is variation in land
prices in swindon but if I keep the same
range of values on the vertical axis to
make sure that I I light this difference
between the two the two postcodes and
this is my I wanted to to leave some
some time from for Q&A so this is my
conclusion slide there is a big gap in
UK statistics its UK economic statistic
n which is the fact that we don't know
anything at present about land and land
prices that there is a solution is to
put together it's not to collect new
data is just to put together data that
is already out there and especially
merging geographic data using Python and
QGIS it's a great way to put together
information that we have on building
sizes and on land plot sizes and
therefore decompose house price
into structure and land this is a work
in progress and I'm very happy to hear
if you have suggestions comments etc
thank you very much I was wondering if
your results
yeah no that's that's a great suggestion
I we definitely do that the thing we
already thought of doing is to take this
VOA pricing the switch which I'm sure
you you know about an estimate our data
on this world ranged and check whether
in that 1995 to 2010 range we kind of
match the same same pattern but yeah
direct land says is a great of course
this is what we is a great comparison
problem with London direct land sales as
far as I know is that you don't see many
of those in in the center of cities
obviously because because Lana is
already occupied by structures so so
that could be problem but for more the
more peripheral area does that's the
best check we can we can do yes thank
you yeah i mean that's crucial obviously
and so the way i think a good proxy for
this quality i mean one that can be
backed up by the data is the age of the
of the structure which one proxy is one
of the many and so the language she
starts I mean as far as I know we don't
have a data set with the age of
buildings in this country I mean some
agencies like the VOA I guess have this
information and local authorities have
this information to compute council tax
bands but I don't think this information
is public so what we can do is to use
the Land Registry price play data which
starts in 1995 we have an indicator
variable which tells you whether the
building is new or not if something was
built after 1994 we can we can derive
the age of the building and then the
something the other thing we can do is
assume that in the same local area the
quality will be more emoji news than
between two different local areas and
allow for this level average differences
between between errors and yet we need
to think about I mean even more ways but
of course
definitely obviously are in the fact
that yeah many many you know government
organization are involved in this kind
of questions we see this as a public
good so once it's going to be out there
you know I will won't be able to use it
and then of course yeah other people
could use the land price data to infer
way to predict things about the future
of some local housing markets so if we
manage to do this so I have derived land
values for individual houses then as far
as i know that will be the first country
to have those values I've seen a papers
from the US they do this for Washington
DC and one one thing that they find
which relates to what you're saying is
that you can for each house set the
composer price into structure and land
and you have the share of value that is
associated to land rather than structure
they find that this as a predictive
value on the amount of price increased +
or price for those houses have
experienced so that super super useful
information yeah yes you mentioned that
there is a big gap in the statistics but
do you think sort of the private
companies that you also talked about
that that sort of indicate the price
price index and all that do you think
they do already do this but you just
mean for open source point of view it's
there is a lot of scope I'm sure big
developers and you know people in need
your market practitioners I'm sure they
have estimates of land values yeah yeah
definitely so so that would be more like
a public good open source kind of
approach to the problem but also perhaps
due to you know insert some rigor not
not in the sense that we were saying
that the values will be getting and will
be the exact ones but at least is
producible but other people so if we
make mistakes so we do something wrong
other people can say do this in this way
whereas for private companies that
estimate a nice we don't know how to get
at those values
yes oh so that's in the dispersed phase
of the project that's what we do because
conceptually we still need to think how
to interpret the little arrangement
where presumably well they could be
literal arrangement on a house although
it's not that common or obviously with
you know blocks of flats yeah there we
would see in the Land Registry the
transaction of the leaves old but that
wouldn't capture the entire land value
so we need to think about that I'm not
sure we can do I know yeah I know yeah
no it's it's an issue and the other
thing is how to deal with the flats
right I mean conceptually if we sum the
value of all flats then we will have the
value of the building maybe but yeah I
mean there are many things to take into
account like common areas and stop
that's right yeah yeah yeah the stock is
not initiated that how the stock is made
yes yeah buildings that are being
destroyed just after the sale I see that
a lot is construction for so there's a
building but because they would get rid
of it that's more cost and value of the
vehicle and listen angel is super
impressive I like how you dealt with a
colleague arity looked at the
distribution of land price and how that
shape results as a way to make sure that
your prediction make sense yeah so the
only other research of this kind i am
aware of in the field of economics is
from the US and they they started is
yeah because they wanted to prove the
point that you're building costs are
quite homogeneous across areas and over
time even if they grow obviously but the
i mean we will in general in the
economic in these years in all economic
domains we see an increase of inequality
and in the housing market these
inequalities in land prices is not in
structural prices so say that London has
grown you know a double speed with
respect to another area the UK in the UK
then it's been the land price have grown
even even even more and that's something
we need to study more yes
have you the variability of land prices
going tomorrow within the same let's a
postcode or square mile to construct
some food for let's exist going to
what's really cheap or rich versus the
average of that all that square mile so
that you know adjusting visa blanchett
directly be priced similarly yeah a lot
of variability which could explain yeah
I think it's a good idea whenever we
find variability we always have to think
whether this would be true variability
or some kind of measurement error
because obviously yeah something is
really way out very absolutely yeah yeah
no that's that's good point and related
to this how comes to my mind I according
to many economic models the optimal tax
system would tax land values and no no
and no structure and this obviously know
not what we have at the moment this is
just me as an account it's obviously not
not advocating anything but but the in
theory you know language could be useful
also for for potentially in the very far
future some new ways of taxing the
housing
yeah so we run the regression in each
year so we threw it each year separately
the way the way we dealt with the
coolant collinearity is we had so so
cool and we have different coefficient
every for every year for structure we
only have one coefficient because we
assume that the evolution over the year
is the same for all postcodes then this
will only one coefficient beta 2 maybe
maybe better one should be indexed by T
because if I beta 2 is the same is the
one that makes your line go go up and
down just on a level change but not any
any any any slope change so basically we
take our structure measures and we
multiply them by the building cost index
value for that year and and we impose
the same coefficient on all those values
that's what we do
properties this was sold in 2000's rice
and 3000 and this price
yeah there's definitely enough repeats
in the Land Registry because I've done
other pieces of research focusing only
on repeat sales yeah no that's something
that we haven't thought about but
because presumably you're thinking the
piece of land doesn't change perhaps
there's some change the structure it's
nice variation etc yeah thank you yeah
yeah that's the VOA valuation office
agency oh no we haven't yet no no we
started small yeah well that's the end
goal so as you can imagine I mean we
need to automate these more perhaps
using the Python scripting facilities of
QGIS so so far you know we've been doing
only these two post called it's quite
it's been quite time consuming at as we
get more experienced we will ultimate
everything and I Lumia
yeah I don't have that piece of
information I should have it yeah yeah
but it's very rough so so as of now it's
not super accurate yeah but it's a good
it's a good question okay and I'm here
to discuss with any of you if you have
further further questions thank you